c'est un discours de l'état de l'union
dans un contexte particulier devant le
parlement européen de bruxelles la
présidente de la commission
ursula von der leyen a détaillé sa
vision de l'union européenne poste
qu'ovide 10,9 en fixant plusieurs
priorités en premier lieu la santé des
européens sur wii masque anti new soul
devons donc continuer à affronter cette
pandémie avec la plus grande prudence la
pire une responsabilité est la plus
grande unité un duo need you so for me
et escroquerie ya pour moi c'est une
évidence nous devons construire une
union européenne de la santé qui soit
plus forte
iulian conséquences de la crise
sanitaire l'union européenne a traversé
un choc économique
de nombreux emplois ont pu être sauvées
grâce au chômage partiel financée par
les 90 milliards d'euros du programme
européen sur et la commission souhaite
aller plus loin dans la protection
sociale au lido la commission présentera
donc une proposition législative en vue
d'aider les états membres à mettre en
place un cadre pour les salaires
minimums l'union européenne de demain
passera par une transition
environnementale la commission fixe
comme objectif d'atteindre la neutralité
carbone pour l'europe d'ici à 2050 près
de 30% des 750 milliards d'euros du plan
de relance seront consacrés à
l'environnement
d'ailleurs au pin comme machine la
commission européenne propose de porter
l'objectif de réduction des émissions
pour 2030 à au moins 55 % 4 listes
fifty-five 300 nous améliorerons les
échanges de droits d'émission
promouvront l'utilisation des énergies
renouvelables améliorerons l'efficacité
énergétique et réformerons la fiscalité
sur l'énergie of the ring n' roll match
mais la mission du pacte vert pour
l'europe va bien au delà de la réduction
des émissions elle vise à assurer une
modernisation systémique d'une autre
économique de notre société et de notre
industrie indienne de suite
autre priorité de l'union européenne le
numérique 20% du plan de relance seront
investis dans ce secteur plusieurs
projets dont la création d'un cloud
européens et d'une identité électronique
européenne pour sécuriser les données le
développement des connexions rapides ou
de la prochaine génération de super
ordinateurs